[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce stop
science consacrée aujourd'hui un hommage
au dernier représentant mâle de la
sous-espèce méridionale de rhinocéros
blancs qui nous a récemment quitté
désolé mec les médecines alternatives
ont eu ta peau le pire c'est que l'être
humain et ses croyances bizarre n'en ont
pas fini avec les rhino et c'est
pourquoi cet épisode entier traitera de
l'affluence de l'homme sur ceux qui
l'entourent et la période géologique qui
va avec j'ai nommé l'anthropocène
l'anthropocène c'est la période durant
laquelle l'homme aurait laissé son
empreinte où son influence sur les
phénomènes géologiques sédimentaires
hydrologique écologique et climatique
serait devenu le plus palpable
c'est en afrique du sud en 2016 que les
spécialistes du monde entier se sont
rassemblés et ont décidé que oui
l'anthropocène représentait bien quelque
chose de concret ne reste plus qu'à
faire ratifier tout cela par la
commission stratigraphique
internationale et notre échelle des
temps géologiques aura un nouvel étage
l'anthropocène loges des hommes m'est
arrivé mais commençons par le début
c'est quoi l'échelle des temps
géologiques et ça veut dire quoi de
vouloir y ajouter l'anthropocène afin de
s'y retrouver un peu les scientifiques
ont divisé les temps géologiques en
tranches pas égales du tout de plusieurs
millions d'années
du point de vue des fossiles et chaque
tranche comporte une faune et une flore
pétrifié relativement homogène et
suffisamment différentes des foins des
fleurs des étages qui les entoure pour
l'identifier facilement par exemple
l'ère mésozoïque correspond à l'âge des
dinosaures sur terre et des ammonites
dans les océans
cette manière de diviser le temps a une
conséquence intéressante par définition
chaque étage ainsi identifié est séparé
des états adjacent par des changements
de faune et de flore plus ou moins
dramatiques selon le rang et
l'importance des laitages ainsi une
grande aire comme l'ère mésozoïque est
séparé des autres airs par 2 complète
révolution des écosystèmes les
extinctions permo triassique et crétacé
paléogène deux parmi les plus terribles
extinction de masse que la terre ait
connu mais pour un été agité rend plus
petits comme une période d'une époque
ces changements seront par définition
moins drastiques l'anthropocène serait
une époque un étage de rang inférieur
il correspondrait à l'âge où l'impact de
l'être humain sur les processus gier
serait devenu significatif significatif
à significative oui mais mais
significatif comment s'était dit va
avoir un effet sur l'environnement le
climat les processus géologiques tout ça
c'est bien gentil mais met l'humain il
en a pas de monopole de ces influences
il n'y a qu'à voir les éléphants qui
déracine les arbres au point d'en
transformer une forêt en savane en
quelques semaines
ou bien les migrations en masse des
grands herbivores si grandes qu'elles
peuvent parfois changer le cours d'une
rivière ou bien encore les oiseaux de
proie qui répandent les feux de brousse
en transportant délibérément des brady
s'enflammer sur des kilomètres afin de
faire sortir leurs proies de leur
cachette
eh oui ne vous déplaise notre espèce
n'est pas la seule à répandre la
destruction pour faciliter c'est
l'existence et c'est sans compter que
les animaux ont des effets non
négligeables sur les taux de
sédimentation en creusant des galeries
ou en apportant des débris dans les
grottes et bien sûr dans certaines
parties du monde la sédimentation est
principalement d'origine biologique
marais tourbières et certains coins de
l'océan la vie elle-même fait parfois la
géologie alors comment en arrive-t-on à
dire que l'uma serait un facteur
géologique plus important que balou
septembre des cocos ni de quoi par
exemple 1 premièrement il ya la
sédimentation induite par l'homme les
techno fossiles comment ils appellent
les activités humaines sont responsables
d'un relargages d'une quantité
importante de déchets notamment du
plastique dans les océans et il est fort
probable que les générations futures
reconnaîtront l'anthropocène comme une
fine couche de sédiments fait en grande
partie de plastique le septième
continent un vortex de déchets
rassemblés par les courants de l'océan
pacifique en contiendrait 79 milles
tonnes à lui tout seul
de quoi recouvrir complètement le québec
ou bien l'algérie sous les déchets le
deuxième facteur est l'eutrophisation
enr larguant des nitrates en excès dans
les points d'eau l'agriculture intensif
favorise la prolifération de bactéries z
algues qui consomme tout l'oxygène de
l'eau tu la vie aquatique et provoquent
la mort est finalement l'obstruction des
poinot mais c'est pas un phénomène
naturel sa psy mais il est aggravée par
les activités humaines de façon non
négligeable
troisièmement l'urbanisation l'élevage
et l'agriculture utilise presque un
quart des terres émergées
ces surfaces sont en proie à une érosion
intense car le couvert végétal qui est
insuffisant ainsi qu'à un
appauvrissement des sols et des
ressources naturelles
s'ajoute à cela la fragmentation des
tu as pour les espèces sauvages qui se
retrouve dispersé en population trop
petit pour continuer à se reproduire
dans de bonnes conditions
quatrième facteur faisant de l'espèce
humaine un facteur géologique important
l'inévitable réchauffement climatique
en relâchant du co2 et d'autres gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère
l'humanité est responsable d'un
accroissement visible de la température
qui a eu lieu sur les 100 ou 200
dernières années cela va de pair avec
des changements météorologiques tels
qu'une augmentation des événements météo
extrêmes ou bien encore des sécheresse
sans précédent comme en afrique du sud
justement en effet au cap où il avait
ironiquement été décidé que
l'anthropocène n'était pas une fable
les faibles précipitations de ces trois
dernières années met aujourd'hui 4
millions de gens face au risque de ne
plus avoir accès à une seule goutte
d'eau potable au-delà du problème posé
pour l'agriculture ce sera bientôt
l'hygiène le principal challenge 5e
facteurs les extinctions d'espèces
évidemment on ne compte plus les espèces
qui se sont éteintes de suite des
activités humaines la surpêche et la
déforestation à elles seules doivent
être responsables de plus d'extinction
de plantes d'invertébrés et de poissons
par décennie qu'on a pu en compter
depuis le siècle dernier
mais bon comme il s'agit pour la plupart
des espèces qui nous resteront pour
toujours inconnue bah ça passe quand
même
le problème c'est qu'un écosystème est
une organisation complexe un réseau
d'interactions en équilibre instable et
que retirer une espèce de ce délicat
équilibre est comme un jeu de jeunes
gars on ne sait jamais quand tout va
s'effondrer
nous n'en sommes pas encore aujourd'hui
à une extinction de masse car une trop
faible fraction de la biodiversité est
concerné mais s'il ya bien une chose
qu'on sait à propos des extinctions de
masse c'est que le jour où ça va arriver
même les rats et les cafards ne seront
pas à l'abri enfin sixième et dernière
influence majeure que l'homme assure la
géologie
c'est le transport d'espèces invasives
laissons de côté le fait que les espèces
invasives concurrence espèces
autochtones participant ainsi à leur
déclin les chats les souris et les rats
par exemple sont directement
responsables de la disparition de près
de 140 espèces mais ça va dans le point
numéro 5 non non parlons plutôt du fait
que les plantes invasives sont bien
souvent beaucoup plus gourmandes en eau
que ne le sont les espèces autochtones
bien adapté à la sécheresse local
parlera aussi de la brume des murs
originaire du vieux continent et qui
prolifèrent en amérique du
or particulièrement en californie où
elle constitue un carburant remarquable
pour les feux qui ravagent régulièrement
la région
cette plante vivace repos si vite que
les incendies ne sont jamais en panne de
carburant comme celle ci de nombreuses
espèces de plantes invasives bouleverse
les régimes de feu des écosystèmes à
travers le monde
et du côté animal vous pourrez
contempler les ragondins de nos fleuves
qui sont en fait originaire d'amérique
du sud et qui massacrent les berges de
nos cours d'eau bon ok tu m'as convaincu
l'espèce humaine a bien un effet global
significative sur la géologie de la
planète à six sur son climat et sa
biodiversité
ah je veux mon neveu et puis de toute
façon les coccolithes ils ont déjà une
époque qui leur est dédié à eux et à
leurs effets sur la sédimentation
ah oui et ça s'appelle comment le coco
dit hossein et non sécréter c'est bien
bref donc admettons que l'homme a
effectivement un effet notable sur la
géologie et qu'il mérite bien qu'on lui
dédie une période l'anthropocène
maintenant faudrait voir à lui donner un
début et une fin à cette période et le
gros problème de l'anthropocène c'est
conséquent il se termine maintenant oui
maintenant oui maintenant oui attentats
maintenant oui merci c'est bon je crois
qu'ils ont compris l'idée à d'accord
maintenant
maintenant je disais donc on sait quand
il se termine mais la grande question
est de savoir quand il commence quand
l'impact de l'homme sur la géologie et
tim devenu significatif plusieurs dates
possibles ont été proposées par les
géologues serait ce qu'au début de
l'holocène quand l'arrivée de l'homme en
australie et en amérique a provoqué
l'extinction des majestueuses faune de
mammifères géants qui avait élu domicile
peut-être oui mais cette période porte
déjà un nom c'est le lot scène alors
peut-être faut-il le faire commencer à
la date du tout premier essai nucléaire
les bombes atomiques relâche une grande
quantité de césium radioactif dans
l'atmosphère ce césium permettrait
aisément dater le début de
l'anthropocène et ce partout dans le
monde
ok oui ce serait pratique mais enfin les
premiers essais nucléaires remonte à la
seconde guerre mondiale les faits notre
espèce sur la planète est bien plus
vieux que ça quand même
bon ok on peut utiliser la date de la
révolution industrielle qui est marqué
par la date du dépôt du brevet de la
machine à vapeur en 1784 ben oui je veux
bien mais tu fais quoi de l'agriculture
et de la déforestation ça remonte à bien
avant ça moi je dis qu'il faut utiliser
l'invention de l'agriculture au
néolithique
oui mais ça c'était que dans le
croissant fertile ça n'a rien de global
faut utiliser une date qui marque
l'arrivée
l'agriculture à grande échelle partout
dans le monde comme la découverte de
l'amérique par christophe colomb en 14
192 à partir de là on est sûr que la
mondialisation des effets de l'homme
avait commencé
et pourquoi attendre christophe colomb
les amérindiens pratiquer l'agriculture
avant lui non alors pourquoi pas
utiliser l'arrivée du premier homo
sapiens en amérique il ya quatorze mille
ans pourquoi pas l'apparition de
l'espèce humaine tant qu on y est ah bah
ça ça existe déjà et ça s'appelle le
quaternaire et puis de toute façon ils
utilisent même plus sept étages alors on
va pas le ressuscité juste pour y
changer son nom on se calme les enfants
la meilleure façon de définir
l'anthropocène c'est de prendre la plus
vieille pierre taillée connu daté d'il y
à 3 3 millions d'années en effet c'est
le premier impact de l'homme sur la
géologie à la pierre taillée la paille
sur la géologie à comprendre la blague
les deux les deux c'est nul en
conclusion vous l'aurez compris il n'y a
pas de consensus sur qu'on devrait
commencer l'anthropocène et même si vous
regardez cette vidéo alors qu'une
décision finale a été prise par la
nomenclature ad stratigraphie vous
pouvez être sûr que des voix dissonantes
d'ores et déjà s'élève au firmament de
la controverse menaçante est gros mais
lente que la date choisie est débile car
elle laisse de côté une dimension plus
ou moins importantes d influence humaine
sur l'environnement qui l'entourent de
toute façon quelle que soit la décision
qui a été prise faire de l'anthropocène
une période n'est par définition pas un
choix très judicieux
ah oui à cause de la fierté que ça peut
engendrer comme ses sales gosses sur la
plage qui sont contentes détruire des
châteaux de sable des autres oui oui
enfin non non c'est parce que je veux
dire ok signa un crime de son nom comme
une oeuvre d'art c'est clair que c'est
pas très judicieux niveau pédagogie mais
c'est pas là que je veux en venir
ce que je veux dire c'est que
l'entreprise correspond à une période de
changements climatiques et
environnementaux rapide qui n'aura au
mieux qu'une faible épaisseur
stratigraphique aucune visibilité dans
l'histoire géologique temps il sera
court mais aura certainement un impact
tel qu'il y aura un avant et un après
anthropocène mais alors on est
complètement à côté de la plaque
l'anthropocène n'est pas un état
géologique c'est en fait une séparation
entre deux étages géologique
oui espérons seulement que l'état
géologique qui suivra ne sera pas un art
en trop
détesterait avoir à faire face à notre
propre extinction de masse merci à tous
[Musique]